meetings they're the bane of every
office employee and something you have
to go to regularly if you want to keep
your job but that's where your
responsibility ends you just have to go
you don't have to do much beyond that
I've developed a few simple ways to
appear engaged in a meeting when in
actuality you're calculating what year
you're gonna die in your head first
technique fish face you do not fish
sleep with their eyes open that's
basically what you're doing here pick a
point at the front of the room while
making your mind a total blank and it's
almost like you're asleep
except you can still see everyone but my
mindfulness app says it counts as rest I
know what you're thinking what if you're
asked for your input go with something
basic and vague I like something like
wow I've honestly never thought about it
that way or it sounds like we're at a
natural stopping point or they always
risky that last part actually concerns
me generally everyone wants the meeting
to be over as soon as possible so no one
will ask you to expand on what you meant
but if someone does you can always fire
back with I think we should try and get
back on track lastly if you're a doodler
always doodle after the person speaking
has made a natural pause that way while
it will appear like you are diligently
taking notes you're actually practicing
your signature your signature after you
Mary Alexander Skarsgard I mean an old
classic
you